so without further ado let me introduce
seeing Dan kahan so those who work in
the field of climate change in just
about any aspect of it are frustrated
when they puzzle the font the you know
the question why doesn't the rest of the
world yet why doesn't the general public
really understand that climate change
you know what we're doing to the planet
no really is the defining challenge of
the 21st century and most of us if we
think about it at all we sort of search
our experience you know scratch our
heads and concoct concoct some type of
anecdotal explanation for this and
usually my sort of anecdotal evidence
for the anecdotal explanations are is
that they usually amount to blaming Fox
News or blaming Al Gore if you're
familiar with Dan and his work you'll
know that he actually studies these
problems and looks for hard evidence you
know what really is at the base of these
of these opinions and these sometimes
firmly held beliefs and it's not just on
the area of climate change it's related
to climate I'm sorry to science in
general and the communication of science
so for example he has studied issues
related to why do people go against
conventional wisdom overwhelming medical
evidence and refuse to have their
children vaccinated and their whole host
of questions like this that he studies
in connection with something that he and
his colleagues call the cultural
cognition project and they describe this
as an international team of scholars who
use empirical methods to examine the
impact of group values on perceptions of
risk and related facts before coming to
Yale dan was on the faculty at the
university of chicago school of law he
also clerked for Supreme Court Justice
Thurgood Marshall but I have to say that
the most fascinating fact that appears
on the internet regarding Dan appears on
his website its final sentence short
sentence on one of his web pages it says
and he has a very bad
I dare not ask so Dan is the Elizabeth k
dollar professor of law and professor of
psychology at Yale School of Law and
he's going to talk to us about the topic
on the screen so Dan welcome yes
unfortunately my cat destroyed my slides
and so I'm not able to get this talk
actually it's a tremendous honor to be
asked to be here and address address you
it's it's just a remarkable assembly of
people in a position to address what the
energy needs and opportunities are of
the our future and it's a little bit
awkward of course because I don't know
anything about energy amount know
anything about nuclear power or solar
power I mean I dabble a little bit in
coldfusion I'm just like everybody else
but really I don't know anything maybe
that's why i was on the program for this
evening and not for tomorrow but but
actually mark who's not here said well
you know you really should speak here
even though you don't know anything
about energy and you should speak at the
beginning because what you do know or at
least what you study and people who are
approaching this field in the way that
you are no is a tremendous significance
and consequence for the people who don't
do know what it is we need to know about
energy technologies in the future in
fact he said that the value of what we
can achieve with the knowledge that we
have about new alternative forms of
energy really does depend on connecting
well
not the knowledge that I personally have
but the knowledge of people who study
science communication amen study it in a
scientific way with the knowledge that
you have with the knowledge that
scientists have with the knowledge that
policymakers who use science have that's
essential to realize the value of that
so I said okay I would come and he
didn't come but but that's all I think
he's right and I'm going to try to make
you bleed that but I have already talked
too long without showing some data so
here's some data that this is a scatter
plot of the responses from general
population survey United States from
last summer representing representative
survey where we're asking what do you
think about the risk of climate change
so that's the scale 027 that's on the
y-axis of course and their raid along
the x-axis according their political
outlooks right so you ask them what
their party identification is with a
scale of zero to seven what their
ideology is liberal conservative 02
fighting put those together and you have
a kind of a scale an index of what their
right left political orientations are
and I think you can you can see what the
relationship is maybe you want to see a
plotted regression line there you go but
you know we're running from those kind
of hot colors the climate change is hot
on the extreme left liberal down to the
colder colors for the Conservatives and
that that's a pretty strong correlation
ally is r equals 0.65 you have to kind
of think about these things in
connection with some benchmark but the
correlation between being a conservative
Republican and being a conservative and
being a Republican is about point 65 so
the connection between the people's
positions on this issue is the same as
the connection between what they say
their ideology is and what their party
affiliation is if I wanted to I could
add that
and have that as a third item in my
scale it would only make it more
reliable and I'd be even better at
predicting what people's views are on
issues like abortion or Obama care right
that's how deep the connection is
between people's political outlooks and
climate change now the nice thing about
this measure it what do you think of
climate change on skill is your southern
it doesn't there's no right answer you
see but you use it to measure variance
because it turns out that there's about
a point 9 correlation between what
people will say here and what they'll
say about anything else you ask them
relays the climate change including is
it happening right are humans causing it
well this or that bad consequence occur
as a result so if you look at what
explains the variance in people's
answers to this question how serious do
you think the risk of climate changes
you're really measuring what their
attitudes are what their beliefs are
about facts relating to climate change
so we're polarized you see on the basic
facts and of course you all know this
already but and I know maybe you know
this too it we we look at the
relationship between people's
perceptions of climate change risk their
beliefs about the facts the ones that
admit of scientific investigation and
climate change and their comprehension
of science and you can measure that in
various kinds of ways so here's a scale
that has components that they scale
nicely they measure basically a
disposition to acquire scientific
knowledge how much scientific knowledge
do you have what kinds of critical
reasoning dispositions do you have that
allow you to assimilate empirical
evidence and so forth and what's the
relationship well it looks like there's
none between people's level of science
comprehension and their perceptions of
climate change risks that that's
completely misleading this is a very
very important significant reaction if
you're somebody whose political outlooks
are to the left of center of this divide
the population in half using my index
then as you become more science
comprehending you will become more
concerned about climate change more
likely to believe that the earth is
heating up that humans are causing that
by burning fossil fuels that it has
certain kinds of consequences but if
you're to the right of center then
you're less likely to believe all of
those things right so the degree of
polarization that exists among people
are modest in science comprehension it
only grows it's in more intense among
the people who are in the best position
to understand science right and i'm
going to call this the science
communication problem right this is an
instance of it what the problem is the
persistence of bitter political division
over risks other kinds of policy
relevant facts that not only admit of
scientific investigation but haven't
that been the object of scientific
inquiry of the most compelling kind that
in fact are ones in which information
has been widely disseminated and well
it's it's what we started out with
what's the problem here and this isn't
the only instance of this right I could
show you nuclear power and actually a
lot of the work that I do builds on
research that started 1970 to explain
why there was this conflict between
members of the public and experts on
nuclear power HPV vaccine is another
contemporary example right so we have
this science communication problem it's
the persistence of this division in the
face of the evidence and it's the
existence of a kind of magnification of
conflict as people actually become more
science comprehending right now here's
here's another example of this right
fracking now actually yeah I don't know
people fracking I don't think we know
nearly as much about the risks of
fracking as we know about the risks of
climate change people are just starting
to study these things than they should
right and it's kind of remarkable that
people already this kind of divided
about it but it's not just remarkable
it's very disturbing it doesn't matter
what you think about fracking
because it doesn't matter if things are
like this what it is we ever do find out
if you have an issue like this then
information that we have that's valid
that's compelling is not going to dispel
political conflict right it's not going
to create convergence among the people
who know the most and where the best
position understand didn't explain it to
others it's going to drive them a part
right and so you see we want to
understand the science communication
problem it's actually kind of mysterious
if you think about it that makes it
interesting why not study it but it's
also tremendously inimical to our
welfare because no matter what we find
out on an issue if it has this kind of
profile the likelihood that will
assimilate it into our decision-making
is low right and so yeah I think what
I'm trying to understand is a vital
consequence to realizing the value of
what scientists do what you do and I try
to understand why you have this problem
and you scientific methods and pirkle
methods to do so all right so a 4.0
first start with the something that my
explanation theory your call cultural
cognition thesis an explanation for the
science communication problem give you
some evidence and it's not just
storytelling and then something that it
synthesizes it yeah it's the tragedy and
not the comedy of the science
munications Commons and the end the kind
of prescription about protecting the
science communication environment so
start with the cultural cognition thesis
and basically the idea is just that you
can expect people to form and persist in
perceptions of at least certain kinds of
risk and other policy consequential
facts that reflect and reinforce their
commitment to certain kinds of really
important identifying groups and and
that is a way to describe more general
phenomena motivated reasoning my
cultural cognition is an instance of
motivated reasoning
motivated reasoning is where people fit
their understanding of all manner of
information it might be scientific data
it might be logical arguments it might
be what they see with their own eyes to
some goal or interest that is
independent of extracting the truth from
that information and the classic study
was a 1950s one that the researchers
used college students was appropriate in
this case it's called they saw a game so
they asked the undergraduates from two
Ivy League schools to watch a tape of a
football game between their institutions
the referee made some controversial
calls just watch the tape and see if he
got the right call and so all the
students what wasn't Yale students
because they would have wouldn't wear
all the darkness students watch it oh
you know what's wrong the referee you
know he must have been on the payroll of
pen or something like that in the pen
students what's going on this is your
Dartmouth alum and so forth right so
this is motivated reasoning reasoning
did the emotional stake that the
students have informing judgments about
this important event involving their
group that reflect their commitment to
this group that expressed their
solidarity is influencing what they see
you see so the cultural cognition thesis
is well similar thing is happening
people are making sense of any and all
kinds of information about climate
change and these other issues that
display this profile in a way that
connects them to their groups right and
what are the groups you know you could
define them in lots of different ways
obviously political affiliations are a
group right but we do we use a different
scheme tell you why if you like but it
so it's a little bit more nuanced and we
get this from from Mary Douglas we call
the cultural cognition thesis because
she had the theory developed with a long
as an anthropologist along with the
political science test animal dog ski
the cultural theory of risk and Mary
Douglas said you can characterize
people's worldviews edges preferences
about how society or other kinds of
groups should be organized along these
two cross-cutting dimensions how
individualistic a communitarian how
hierarchical how a gala tarea fairly
straightforward concepts and the idea
was
people are going to form perceptions of
risks that reflect and reinforce their
commitment to one or another group whose
outlooks can be characterized according
to this kind of framework right and so
you know the people who are more
hierarchical individualistic they're
going to be more skeptical about well
nuclear power was really what she was
talking about and the agallah Therrien
communitarians they think that markets
are the source of all kinds of injustice
they want to see commerce market and
industry is causing harm and so they
don't like nuclear it's kind of a
controversial book you see but you you
we can find these kinds of correlations
measuring people's outlooks with scales
that indicate your reliably measure that
there's something in them they seem to
have these kinds of outlooks and they're
these correlations and there are lots of
them not just with with climate change
but with all the kinds of little really
controversial issues that the big hot
button once the kinds of ones you know
you you're in a talk with somebody you
don't know you try to steer away from it
because you really don't want to annoy
anybody okay but we call this cultural
because that's our understanding of what
the relevant groups are here that that
are the source of the motivation these
groups that are defined with reference
to the values that that correspond to
the two by two are to our research what
the school affiliations were to the
subjects the students and they saw a
game right but we say cognition I mean I
told you a little story about the
gallatin and what stories i want to know
what are the psychological mechanisms
that connect commitment to these kinds
of groups and these kinds of outlooks
and so to give example of some studies
here one is on scientific consensus I
and obviously that this is at the core
of the science communication problem we
have scientific consensus why is their
political conflict on these issues and
we do we do it an experiment here what
we did we show people these scientists
right you can see that they're there
they're all scientists of course and
well one of them went to a great
institution I'm two of them a pretty
good landing since my contract you got
that on the film um that they're they're
all
all members of National Academy Sciences
is pretty pretty impressive they all are
working in these these areas area as
well global warming nuclear power gun
control and we're saying to the subjects
just ordinary members of the public did
he seem like experts you I mean if
somebody a friend of yours was trying to
make up his or her mind on this issue do
you think it would make sense for that
person to read a book say by somebody
like this is personal i could get nought
the heck he's talking about right and we
picked these these issues because we
knew that people who have these kinds of
group affiliations that we measure are
divided on what the risks of nuclear
power and climate change and also
carrying concealed weapons it may cry
and go up because i'm 20 guns around
makes crime go down yeah if every scary
p i'll be on my best behavior i want to
piss you off you might be carrying a gun
right and we're giving them you know
here are these people's experts on that
and we tell half the subjects that the
featured scientist says taking we call
the high risk position for climate
change it's beyond scientific dispute
scientific consensus it's happening
caused by humans bad things will happen
low risk too early to say computer
models are fallible need more
information right same geologic nuclear
waste very dangerous no can do that
perfectly safely or conceal weapons you
know crimes what crime is going to go
down and the answer then that people get
to the question is this a expert depends
on what the correlation is between the
position were attributing to the
scientists and the cultural outlooks of
the subject who's answering the question
right so if you're if you're an
egalitarian communitarian and that
scientist you saw is saying yes climate
change is happening it's a fifty-four
percent point increase in the likelihood
relative to a high curl individual state
yeah that's an expert but if your are
the actor heichal individuos and he says
it's not happening fifty-four percent
seventy two percent point more likely to
the galaxy and communitarian to say you
know he's not an expert if he is shown
to be taking the position on climate
change that it's low risk and you get
similar big effect sizes on these other
issues
now you see this is like they saw a game
these these members of groups who have
these kinds of outlook so divided on
these issues and they understand that
this is something that divides others
and they're being sown some evidence
here no evidence of what somebody who
you might think well knows what he's
talking about it well it depends right
you see that person is having
information that should be credited by
others if it's the doing so is
supportive of what your group says but
not otherwise you see you know this is
not Bayesian reasoning you update your
priors based on their new information
here we're we're using what we already
believe to judge the weight of the
evidence whether this person knows what
he's talking about of course we use he
white males I'll maybe these groups have
different ideas about who should be have
authority based on gender and race but
I'm trying to try to control for that
right shown the same person and if
that's the way the world works you see
then these people are going to be
divided not only on the risk but on what
scientists say and that's true none of
the people in these groups think that
scientific consensus is inconsistent
with the one that predominates in their
group right you know happens you just
say to them well what am I scientists
think you know let's see every every
expert i ever saw said this you know
yeah because you were engaged in by a
sampling you're excluding from your
account essentially people who don't
have the position that you're a group
responsible only not an expert on that
or some so forth and people end up
polarized and they are on these kinds of
issues here's another kind of
explanation will be maybe there's a
group out there to hate scientists you
know they don't think we should listen
to scientists no that's not these groups
in fact on anybody that has much
influence in our culture they all think
you of course do what scientists say you
should do but they're divided on that
neither of them is very good either at
figuring out what scientific consensus
is we pick these issues because the
National Academy of Sciences as issued
consensus reports on each one of these
issues and each group is right about
thirty three percent of the time make
the group that's right in the climate
change wrong a nuclear power both wrong
about guns and National Academy said
can't tell the evidence is inconclusive
no scientific consensus it's not these
groups think so it's not that what do
you think one of these groups is better
than the others I figure out what the
scientists think well then you have to
think it's better to than the national
academy of sciences that's one
possibility the other possibility is
neither is very good that they're doing
what we said in our experiment which is
conforming what they see to the interest
that they have and persisting in the
view that the group is right now one
thing on which they all agree you can
figure out why the climate change is
happening by just considering what the
weather has been like recently right
there are many polls that show that what
people experience the weather to be like
will predict whether they think climate
change is happening but Mike Nicola Thor
Hank Jenkins Smith it was worked on me
with the last study did he showed that
what predicts what people think the
local weather has been recently is not
what the local weather has been in their
area it's their cultural outlooks if
they are a gala tarian communitarian the
group that's predisposed to bleep in
country they think it's been awfully hot
the last few years in their zip code and
if they're hierarchal individual I think
it's really been quite cold right so you
know if your air conditioner bows out
this summer just tell yourself well you
know it is the case that the death
penalty puters murder and maybe it'll
help now we do work in Florida actually
it is the new extension here I've done
this now using our our scheme and
deputies super imposed histograms you
can see you know that that that's kind
of a bipolar distribution they're
bimodal distribution and the the
increased Magnifico magnification of the
polarization conditional on science
comprehension and this is actually just
a replication of a study that we did in
nature climate change and the same
things going on in Florida right I mean
so Florida which is kind of on the
frontier of climate impacts for the
United States same thing but we also
looked at just how how had they already
been affected by adverse weather events
and kind of adverse events index how
often you do vacua to residents your
residents have been damaged by flood
you know it did you ever lose access to
water and so forth insurance rates club
that would throw that one out cuz
everybody said yes in Florida right but
but you know I are about about three and
a half of these bad events have happened
people in these four counties Monroe
County which is the keys Broward
miami-dade West Palm Beach they're all
the southeast counties the ones that get
hit by the Hurricanes right and we want
to know well it does this have an effect
on their understanding of whether
climate change is happening the
perception of the risk right what do you
think is going to happen is people
experience more of these adverse events
will they become more concerned less
concerned he thinks it's a trick
question more concern see mm-hmm anybody
else well here's a question if you know
but I thought you would try to trick me
by saying oh nothing happens right if I
would say no that's a trick question it
only looks like nothing's happening if
you become if you're more egalitarian
communitarian you become more concerned
as more bad things are happening to you
in Florida but if you're a hierarchal
individualist as the bad things happen
you it doesn't have any impact you see
so you know the hurricane comes in and
it knocks down the two houses the guys
across the street from each other yeah
first guy comes running out of his house
and he says you see I told you that the
climate change that happened do anything
now look at my house and there you go
says well will you talk about so bad
told you if we had gay marriage this was
gonna happen right you know something
they both have equal science
comprehension and you know that this is
another one here you see this is
actually another another hypothesis
about the salon communication problem
that people don't actually process
information about risk in a systematic
conscious analytic way the way
scientists do I slow system true but
they they do rely on kind of effective
intuitive heuristic driven processes and
therefore they overestimate more
dramatic risks like the risk of
terrorism
I took the more consequential cares
about the polar bear it makes sense this
is a real mechanism but you know more
things are plausible than our true
that's why you collect data you see and
this theory predicts for one thing that
as people then experience these kinds of
more emotionally compelling things like
their house getting smashed down by a
hurricane or having to evacuate or
losing their water then they'll start to
pay attention well no it's not true and
it's not that surprising because you can
observe the consequences but you're not
observing the cause right what made this
happen climate change or is you know god
matter any just anything else you have
to rely on somebody else to tell you why
things like this happen and then that's
evidence that that's how the world works
that's where the cultural cognition
comes in you see now the theory that we
have a kind of defect in in public
rationality explains climate change also
predicts of course you know that that as
people become better at assimilating
information as they become more disposed
to use the kind of analytic dispositions
associated with the slow conscious
evaluation essential to make sense of
scientific information on risk then they
should become more concerned and I've
already basically shown you that that
that's not true so that's evidence that
tends to count against that thesis to
it's consistent with the cultural
cognition thesis I mean we would say
well we would predict people going to
use their ability to make sense of
information to satisfy the stake that
they have in forming and persisting in
the positions that connect them to their
group and that would fit this you see
but but this is observational data let's
do an experiment and see if we can catch
these critical reasoning dispositions in
the act all right so here's a study we
recently did and we said to people those
scientists we all love them we do in the
United States love scientists at all
these groups they think scientists are
great and come home I'm gonna marry a
scientist mom you look great I'm going
to marry a lawyer what the hell wrong
with you you know it's nothing like this
at scientist we love them because they
do things like
skin rash creams that they've done that
but here's the thing you know sometimes
the skin rash goes away by itself
sometimes gets you know sometimes
actually skin cream can make it worse
you got to test these things so here's
some some data right the scientist gave
the skin cream to some people who had a
rash and didn't give it to others how
many got better got the rash how many
got better who didn't get it and you'll
see right away right is it working or
not you'll go oh it's not working you
know because you can see that the people
got the screen cream well they're about
three times more likely to get better
but the people who didn't there about
five times more likely to get better so
you right right away you got that
because this is a two-by-two contingency
table this is how you establish whether
there's a correlation right that's what
this is about can you can you recognize
covariance right and most people can't
they look at this and they use a
heuristic they say hey more people who
got the treatment got better than what
it works right and then slightly smarter
when say hey also you don't not only
more people god it got better and then
we've got worse the people didn't get it
fewer of them got better it works right
and that's not right you've got to use
all the information that's why we have
the two-by-two contingency right and you
tell this to people afterwards it's not
even get the math and they don't
understand that you have to look at the
disconfirming as well as the confirming
evidence so you oops you know I won't do
that again you will do that again
because this is it this is a great
problem for measuring whether you have a
certain kind of disposition to recognize
that you need to use this kind of
reasoning to make a causal inference
right now we have another version of the
experiment say no scientist this time
they looked at the city so which adopted
a gun ban some of which didn't they want
to see crime going up or down and we
changed the headings on the public all
these experimental manipulations not
sure why but you change the headings on
the columns so that half the subjects
will or one quarter for each of the but
half the people who see one version of
it will see that the the table where if
the data are properly construed the rash
is getting better or where crime is
going down the other half see the
information in the form in which oh well
you know the
that crime is going up and the rash is
getting worse and you want to see how
people do and so here's the data and I
actually look at this way it's a raw
data but you basically the people
getting it right people getting it wrong
you know the different colors you know I
had well we look at their numeracy which
is a an ability not just do math but to
reason with quantitative information in
a appropriate reliable way and make
inferences from it that are actually
valid right and here you see as people
are getting higher in numeracy they're
more likely to get the right answer
about the skin cream right there is no
matter which condition they're in but
they're low and numeracy like to get
wrong so hard problem you gave you about
with an 85th percentile before you're
you're much more likely to get it right
than not all right great Tesla probably
on the SATs so you probably already saw
it right now here's what happens with
the gun ban all right looks weird
there's some noise in there right and
that's cultural cognition here we're
measuring people's political outlooks if
you do it that way if you want just
another way to measure what these
dispositions are and if you look at the
skin rash version of the treatment those
high partisan subjects it doesn't matter
what what their political affiliation or
outlook is they're getting it right but
not the ones who are low right in
numeracy it comes the gun ban people are
getting the answer right if they're
hiring numeracy if the data properly
construed we supports the conclusion
it's consistent with the one that
corresponds with their ideology and
otherwise they're doing no better than
their low numeracy counterparts this is
funny to you you think this is funny all
right make you laugh that it's not funny
you see this isn't funny iodized I
school but you know you people just show
you this pathway I don't look at this
actually let's make some you're gonna
graphically present these things the way
a climate scientist do I don't want
Carlos simulate you do otherwise
somebody shows you that they're just
trying to intimidate you what does this
mean you know I'll show you what it
means I'm going to simulate you know
what the likelihood is like a thousand
cells do monte carlo simulation a
thousand people who have
say a liberal outlook one standard
deviation from the mean in favor of
liberalism and who are low in numeracy
what would they do in the skin rash
treatment thousand people were
conservatives and low numeracy and
they'll fill out a probability
distribution and you can look at it nor
they they're not doing so well but
they're all kind of clumped together now
let's look at the high numeracy ones
right they're all doing much better the
pretty clump together doesn't seem to be
much difference and now you look at the
gun ban right if I were pulling a
thousand people like this well there's
polarization right and the interesting
thing is that the the degree of
disagreement the difference in how
likely people are to get the right
answer it's lower for the low numeracy
partisans then for the high numeracy
partisans right in both both of these
treatments for the gun right there's
about a difference of twenty five
percentage points and how likely
somebody is to get the answer right
right if it's kind of contrary to their
view for the low numeracy partisans
about forty six percent difference in
the likely forty six percent is more
likely to get it if it's consistent with
your ideology than not if your high end
in numeracy right what what's happening
that the people high numeracy you see
they're smart and they recognize when
the evidence is consistent with their
view and they get it right the loan we
see people they're just as partisan but
they don't even see I can't they're
trying they can't see as readily that
the information supports their view now
when the information doesn't support
their view well then you see these same
high numeracy people they use that same
critical reasoning ability to pop open a
confabulate or e escape hatch to the
logic trap oh there's something wrong
with that study maybe there is but they
only see it when it's inconsistent with
their view if that's the way the world
works and it could do this with culture
too you're going to see this right those
people who are high in critical
reasoning are more divided because
they're using their critical reasoning
abilities in this opportunistic way
that's what the the cultural cognition
thesis but not the others would predict
and this tragedy the science mutations
comments it's not a comedy right you see
it
this problem this kind of division on
issues that admit a sign of a fact
factual empirical investigation that
that become worse as people become more
science comprehending that's not a
problem obviously with two little
rationality that's too much you see
people are too good at extracting from
information on these issues the
significance that helps them align with
their groups and that's a rational thing
to do because it doesn't matter what any
individual ordinary person that leads
out of your koch brothers ordinary
individual doesn't matter what they
think about climate change they don't
matter enough as a consumer as a voter
as somebody making arguments to have an
impact on what the policy is or to have
an impact on carbon emission mitigation
and so forth even if they decide not to
go completely carbon free if they make a
mistake based on the science and any of
those capacities nobody gets hurt
doesn't change the risk for them or
anybody they care about make a mistake
though about climate change given what
it signifies about who you are for
people who care who are like you that
could be very bad if I go out right now
with the big science does you know it's
a hoax even with ten year my life is
going to suck you know you know Bob
Inglis the most conservative congressman
in history right if fourth district
south carolina gets knocked out of
office by a tea party challenger why
because he said he believes in climate
change right so you're Floyd the barber
in the 4th district of South Carolina
and now the guy comes in for the shave
you straight razors are you sign my
petition on polar bears before you leave
you know you're out of a job as quickly
as Bob Inglis not a good idea you see
and you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to know what kinds of issues
are like that and to align yourself with
these positions or you know you don't
have to be very smart to adopt a way of
making sense of the world that will
reliably connect you to the position
that predominates in your group on in a
situation like this but if you are very
good at math you are very good at
argument you can just do even better you
won't think more like a scientist you'll
just be a more reliable indicator of
what people like you happen to think on
these issues right and
they'll be very good for you but it'll
be very bad for everybody if we all do
this at once you see because then in a
diverse society we're less likely to
converge on the best available evidence
that might be of tremendous significance
to our welfare that doesn't change the
incentive of any individual though to
continue going on in the way that he or
she would are these circumstances
because whenever they do individually
won't make enough difference that's a
collective action problem it's a tragedy
of the Commons it's a tragedy of the
science communication Commons and you
know to fix it well you have to you have
to you have to treat this as an
environmental problem you see this is
not normal right I mean it's not this is
normal right and this is normal the
number of issues where you see the kind
of partisan or group affiliation based
division on issues that admit of
scientific investigation that becomes
even more intense as people become more
more science literate that the orders of
magnitude fewer of those then there are
like the one on top right why not
because people are they're experts on
medical x-rays you know or something
like that but we need to get the hay
biologists tell us something about
science communication because you
obviously everybody is on board with
pasteurization of milk or just about
everybody I mean there's some people but
they're way out there there's no
cultural conflict no cultural conflict
so everybody must understand
pasteurization right they don't
understand these things you know half
the people United States and that's
actually better than in most other
countries think that if you take an
antibiotic it kills a virus as well as a
bacteria so what you don't need to know
that all they need to know is who the
doctor is and you go to her and you take
care with Rome Iceland you see you need
to accept in order to live much more as
known by science than you could possibly
understand or verify for yourself so you
become an expert and knowing who the
hell knows what they're talking about
and people are really good at it one of
the reasons are good at is they do it in
groups like this you see that they
understand people like them
right they don't fight with them right
they can read them you know they know
who's bullshitting who's telling the
truth so they kind of plugged themselves
in they see what people who know what
they're talking about are doing and they
get the memo and that's okay you see
because his science comprehension is a
culturally random variable if you
thought one of the groups was stupid
that's just more a cultural cognition
right they all have done a study on it I
can show you hey nip ulations and
everything all these groups are amply
stocked with people who know what's
known and with mechanisms for
transmitting what's known to their
members because if they weren't there's
a group out there consistently
misleading its members and what's known
and it's critical their welfare dad you
see so they're all good at it and even
though it's a kind of insular strategy
they tend to converge right that's
normal this is normal did you notice
that the the low numeracy Democrats and
Republicans they don't all have acne
they're listening to their more highly
numerous counterparts and getting the
memo right this is pathological this
occurs when a position on an issue that
admits of some science scientific
inquiry takes on some kind of symbolic
significance as a kind of marker of
somebody's membership in and loyalty to
a group it becomes entangled in these
meanings at which point the state that
people have in forming and persisting in
beliefs that connect them to the group
will tend to dominate the one that they
have in forming truth convergent
understandings right that's not the norm
but it happens right that's a polluted
science communication environment those
meanings that attach to the positions
and create a stake for members of these
groups and forming positions that are
odds with each other that make
correlation between going with your
group and what position you believe in
those disrupt and disable the normal and
normally reliable faculties that people
use in an unpolluted science
communication environment to figure out
what's known right those include using
your critical reasoning capacities but
also your ability to recognize who knows
what they're talking about
in a polluted science medication
environment those are no longer reliable
right so you've got to protect the
science mutation environment right
there's a science communication
environment consists in the sum total of
hues and processes that reliably guide
people to what's known by science the
disruption of those processes by
pollutants like these diese antagonistic
meanings are as an image of a democratic
society as pollutants in the natural
environment are to the health of people
and so you have to fix that fix that
with a with a policy of science
communication environment protection one
that uses as our environmental
protection policy does evidence-based
ways of understanding the kinds of
dynamics that affect the science
communication environment right I don't
so well you use these same kinds of
things I've been talking about to
explain the science munication problem
to try to fix it mitigation strategies
put avoid the pollution or detoxify the
option at adaptation I don't have time
well see this is a trick I want to talk
for two hours by fit well and one half
time I'll just I'll just define the
problem and not have time for the
solutions you can ask me about that in
questions right but I would show you
study so we can you get a forecasting
maybe a new technology like like
nanotechnology does it have a future
like this can we get in front of it
right this isn't an environment
forecasting most people don't know about
fracking yet they don't need to know
much before they polarize but we should
try to do something if we can if we if
we can't prevent it from happening then
we have to clean things up and there are
ways to clean things up you want to
disentangle the meanings from the
position so that people don't have this
this incentive as individuals to form
assessments of the information in a way
that doesn't fit society's interest in
the use of truth convergent strategies
can you disentangle a detoxification
adaptation you see because I think we're
going to be stuck with a polluted
science communication environment on
Climate maybe for quite a while possibly
on other issues
but is there something we can do if we
understand the mechanisms at work
reliably to activate or maybe maybe
supplement the kinds of reasoning
dispositions that people usually rely on
to figure out what's known right maybe I
can make people curious because if you
curious you have an appetite to know
something you didn't to be surprised by
it right and if you're in that kind of
frame I show me you know I'm going to
love finding out what what what I didn't
get then you're not in this kind of
defensive posture and what how can we
promote curiosity or move some of these
conversations to places where people are
curious right and i can tell you tell
you some things about that too but
there's probably not time how
geoengineering can make people curious
and reduce polarization amount of time
but it also doesn't matter because you
know these are just models really of how
you would do something like this you got
to go out there you got it you thought I
work at this you got to do experiments
reproduce in the field what what we can
see works in the lab right and you know
science munication and Environment
Protection that's a public good to just
like protects the natural environment is
he okay individuals can't do it you got
to have you got to have organized action
so yeah this is one of the themes of the
National Academy of Science assistance
leading the way science of science
munication well understand that people
use scientific methods try to understand
how it is people come to know what's
known but understand too that what we
need is a change in our social practices
is so we don't have this divorce between
the knowledge of how people come to know
things from the knowledge that science
produces and that's used in policymaking
because it's that divorce that caused
the problem like climate change that
causes us not to get the value of the
knowledge in the HPV vaccine and you can
do things by communicating you can do
but but your members to of institutions
the science here you're a member of a
profession that's in a position to do
something you're in a university where
you can create programs that bring
together the knowledge that's being
generated
about how to make the world work and how
people can reliably be made to know
about what's important for their
decision-making right that will solve
the problem if we then apply ourselves
to it using methods of science using
reason right to protect reason from
these kinds of challenges to it right
now the problem is the cats but of
course I don't have time for that I
could tell you about some interesting
experiments with cats right but that's
all I have to have to say unless people
have questions that aren't very hard